welcome to my christopher nolan's
[Music]
with Dunkirk right around the corner I
thought it'd be fun to talk about the
Christopher Nolan films that I haven't
yet reviewed on my channel and that
means following his very first film
which was made for a budget of six
thousand dollars this is one of the
least expensive films ever made that had
a theatrical release and this film is
about a man who begins to grow an
obsession with following people around
he doesn't want to do anything to them
he's not a serial killer he's just very
interested in people he's fascinated by
their everyday lives where they go to
work where they drink their coffee and
eventually someone he follows notices
and comes up to him and says look you
like doing this you want to take it one
step further let's go to people's houses
let's break in and see we can find let's
learn about their lives from the inside
not just by following them and similar
to Nolan's next film memento following
has a very fractured narrative sometimes
we jump forward in time and then we jump
backward unlike memento which breaks
these sequences up by showing some in
color and summon black and white this
entire film is in black and white and so
we're able to tell the difference
between time periods because the main
character has changed his hairstyle or
sometimes we'll get an insert shot of
something that's confusing like him
coughing up a rubber glove and we won't
understand why that's imperative to the
story until much later so legend says
that Nolan was only able to shoot this
movie on weekends and for a very short
period of time with actors that he knew
that took him a long time to make the
film is very short already at like
barely 70 minutes and so it took him
apparently about a year to make this
movie because he was very constrained by
the schedule of everyone working on this
movie and this movie is a great example
to show people that you do not need a
gigantic budget or a list stars or
really a studio behind you at all to be
able to make a film that's good it's an
investing story told in a unique way
from the perspective of a filmmaker who
has a voice and it's not about special
effects
it's not about amazing camera work it's
just about the moments between
characters and eventually some big
reveals that happen along the way for
his first real movie in such a small
budget this is actually kind of amazing
he was able to take a story and portray
his voice accurately
through the camera if you go back and
read those early reviews from the late
90s when this movie hit a lot of critics
called Nolan a great rising talent and
they were right he has gone on to prove
that he can do considerably better than
this
I don't consider following a great film
by any means it's far too short to get
really invested in the characters some
of the acting can get a little iffy it's
mostly pretty good but the action
sequences including a close quarters
combat scene and a scene it involves a
hammer and some fingers really do not
live realistic at all and you can tell
that Nolan and the actors just weren't
really prepared for that type of stunt
work and it shows through pretty
obviously in the film also I saw memento
first and then later went back and
watched following and you can see the
shades of what he wanted to do the
bigger picture of what he wanted to do
with a narrative in following that he
eventually perfected in memento and
we'll talk about that soon but with this
film you can tell that he hadn't quite
cracked the perfect way to do a
fractured narrative but he came super
close I think following is a very good
film especially considering its very
small budget I'm going to give it a B so
guys stay tuned for more Nolan reviews
I'm going to review every film of his
that I haven't already reviewed on my
channel so that means memento insomnia
the prestige and believe it or not
Batman Begins I have a Dark Knight
review and a Dark Knight Rises review on
my channel but not Batman Begins and I
know I want to slap myself in the face
to be honest dad Chris guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you